good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy thursday hope
everyone is having an
amazing week we are ready for a great
day jackie and i are here
and we are excited to talk
yes this is such a busy day for me
because i am moving
and i just did a little mid-move toast
you know
an mmt it's so important to do i'm sure
people watch my stories like oh my god
it's 9 30 like you're still in your
apartment right
are you gonna toast and i'm just here to
tell you of course i will be here for
you guys
so i'm like so jealous because olivia
just moved and you're moving and you're
really like moving on up
both of you just like moved within your
buildings but it's like bigger better
more spacious apartments
and i'm like jealous that i'm like in my
same
old apartment but like i'm so not
jealous of moving like
the physicality is just awful like the
day of isn't even that bad it's the week
after with all the boxes
all the boxes yes i haven't gotten to
that phase yet but i
like my move is going by so speedily
this morning like if this episode goes
too long i think i'm gonna miss the move
that's crazy i know but and i that
sounds like something that i would want
to do
but i do like to know like which boxes
are wear so i gotta get home but before
i do it we just have to hit you with the
past five stories that you need to know
we just have to
and like precursor today's episode
yesterday was like the biggest news day
in housewife's history just like
so much went on so this will be a very
housewives heavy show especially because
we're housewives
of salt lake city was on last night as
was real housewives of orange county but
you know my memory is bad and i forgot
that last week or two weeks ago that's
why we deemed it optional
yeah and we vowed to like stop recapping
it but i like was up all night watching
so
no well we didn't bow to stop because it
was like if you watch or i watch we'll
talk about it
but it's no longer mandatory viewing for
the morning toast and the morning
toasters
but you forgot that so yeah so i will
give like a little bit of a recap
because i actually have a lot of very
strong feelings
oh good and i'm here just to defend my
queen elizabeth vargas because
everyone's gonna listen
queen elizabeth the seventh everyone is
coming for her and it's not fair
okay cool i'm interested to hear from
your mouth what happened not from
watching two hours of television yeah no
last night was a long night for tv but
i'm really enjoying real housewives of
salt lake city i have to say i mean
there's something about it that's just
on another level like not even better
than everything else but in a different
category it's like the quality is
supreme like the editing the music the
women are so
interesting it's only episode four and
so much like it's really they have a
nice rhythm like every
everyone sort of knows where they're at
like it's just
really really good i think it's very
obvious and it has been in a few
situations that they had been
filming for a while before we saw the
first episode like before the first
episode
the first piece of footage that was
actually used they had been filming for
i feel like a few months so they had
gotten into a rhythm and there wasn't
that like awkward housewives like
introduction period you know yes
and i think that was a good idea
something they did was just very good
it's coming off really well and i'm
looking forward to recapping it i just
like got so excited about real houses in
salt lake city
i hardcore like spit all over my my chin
oh
i'm just excited today sorry i mean good
we love excitement
excitement excites us i came out a
little strong it happens
um well how was your day yesterday my
day yesterday was busy just you know
with the move
looming like we were doing movie stuff i
also
um i had a lot going on but i i found
time to have dinner with kayla which was
just like so beautiful and stunning
and i got a new phone but i haven't set
it up yet i can't believe that my phone
screen has been cracked
since i filmed my day in the live vlog
in quarantine in
april yeah well i can believe it because
every time i see your instagram story
i'm like why is jackie
phoning in from an android from mars i
know it's really
it's really bad and i'm looking forward
i got the iphone 12
pro max max pro it's gonna be so huge
like i'm going to have carpal tunnel
but at least my selfies will be on point
and i can stop bar every time i need to
like film like premium content
in the selfie mode i like have to borrow
someone else's phone yeah it's like
really annoying well i'm at that time
you know it's that time of year when
apple starts releasing all their new
products so all their old products just
start to
you know mysteriously stop working my
airpods like don't charge
my iphone is like always freezing so i
might be in the new market for like a
new computer iphone
uh airpods because they it's just it's
always just such a coincidence you know
all my products
start to stop working and and i always
do the updates like i'm i always take
care of my products
yeah i take care take care of them i do
but you also get new ones you know tim
cook is like up my ass like knowing what
i'm doing every five seconds and now i
have to get a new phone because of him
well getting a new phone is exciting so
i'm excited to set that up later today
that'll be a fun activity for me
um even though i probably won't set it
up to like next week knowing me that's
by the way people like that no i've
never i've never been someone like that
i've never been someone like that but
like now that i didn't do it the minute
that i got it because i was really busy
last night
um i'm just worried that i'm gonna keep
putting it off i got ben
for i think maybe valentine's day uh the
new iphone because he was like talking
about like for weeks leading up about
how his phone is like cracked
and it never works but he's just so busy
he never gets to that so i'm like okay
this is kind of like a weird gift it's
more like a gift like a mom gets for
their
son for hanukkah yeah but whatever and
he was like so excited about it
it sat in our living room for four
months before he set it up i was
every time i walked by it i was so
insulted i'm like oh my god my husband
hates me you know what else is insulting
that
that cut me again last night because at
mary's
luncheon she gifted all the women a pair
of louis vuitton
air pods and it reminded me of something
that i've buried deep which was after
valentine's day last year i got my
husband those louis vuitton airpods oh i
thought they were the most amazing gifts
like he likes louboutin he loves tech
i was like these are sickening and
apparently the quality is amazing he did
not like them and he returned that oh
like i thought i nailed it 100 but also
how did mary manage to find like eight
pairs they sold out immediately no i
know because she's a queen
and she's acquitted to it she spoke to
god and he just delivered them right to
her door
i love her you know what i actually have
a
totally new perspective on her um and
that's what i love the real housewives
of salt lake city they're also dynamic
you know you have a totally new
perspective on someone who was not
making a mark
on one three two one meredith yeah
love her meredith mark i am a meredith
stan like i've i realize alice
i am a meredith respecter okay and i'm
on my way to
you know a more positive outlook on her
because in the beginning i just thought
she was like
whatever i'm boring but i i loved i
loved what she stood for the other night
i
could not agree more we will discuss
more in our tv recap segment but before
we do that we have to deliver the fast
five so i think and i think without
further ado before i miss my entire move
yeah it's time for the past she learned
her lesson before i missed my entire
move and i don't know where anything is
for the next few weeks
it is time for the best buy stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
yes jaquie that is true you do not lie
to the people but
i do have to say one really quick
anecdote purely
purely anecdotal today's episode is
brought to you by stamps.com
this holiday season more people will be
mailing stuff than ever before
that means the post office is going to
be busy you don't have time for that
stamps.com brings a post office and now
ups shipping
right to your computer you can mail and
ship anything from the convenience of
your home or office
nobody wants to be at the post office
during the holiday season especially
during um like a global pandemic so
stay at home use stamps.com get
everything if you're a small business
and you like ship out
products you gotta use stamps.com if you
have someone you have loved ones all
over the country you wanna send them
your gifts you gotta use stamps.com
they bring the service of the us postal
service and ups right to your computer
it is a must must have for any business
whether you're a small office sending
out invoices
an online seller for filling orders
during their record-setting holiday
season
or even a giant warehouse sending
thousands of packages a day
stamps.com.com can handle it all with
ease
you can print official us postage from
your computer
24 7 for any letter any package any
class of mail anywhere you want to send
once your mail is ready just schedule a
pickup or drop it off it is that simple
plus you get great discounts so there's
tons of benefits to using stamps.com
like you get five cents off every first
class stamp and up to 40
off priority mail and up to 62 percent
off ups shipping rates
not to mention it's a fraction of the
cost of those expensive postage meters
it's a no-brainer saving you time and
money so don't spend a minute your
holiday season at the post office this
year
sign up for stamps.com instead there's
no risk and with our promo code toast
you get a special offer that includes a
four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitment or contracts
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in
toast that's stamps.com enter toast
stamps.com
never go to the post office again and
that's a slogan i can get behind
totally especially in the holiday season
like there's so much shipping to be done
head to stamps.com
first story we have a lot of housewives
news today the first story is big news
real housewives of orange county's
bronwyn wyndham burke
comes out as a lesbian but says she's
still married to her husband
bronwyn wyndham burke is living her
truth the real housewives of orange
county star came out as a lesbian and
revealed she is currently dating a woman
during a candid interview with glad on
wednesday she said quote i like women
i'm gay i'm a member of the lgbtq plus
community it has taken me 42 years to
say that but i'm so proud of where i am
right now
i'm so happy where i am to be able to be
comfortable in my own skin
after so long is just so nice so i watch
the interview
um because i'm like i think most people
just have like questions about
where her marriage lies after this and i
just kind of really respected how like
she just didn't really have an answer
she's like we're doing
our own thing we're taking it day by day
we're sleeping in separate beds but
we're best friends i love him he's my
person
we're co-parenting the kids she's dating
someone yeah a girl named chris
yeah who comes over to the house and
hangs out and the older kids know what's
going on the younger kids
are just like thinking that it's mommy's
friend um so i know that a lot of people
are like confused and like being like
meet her online because they don't
understand it but like i don't know
she's just like making up her own rules
and like let her live
yeah that's literally what she said
they're figuring it out as they go she
said they briefly lived apart earlier
this year while they worked on
redefining their marriage but
she said on watch robin's live like a
few weeks ago that they weren't living
in the same house so i think a lot of
people thought they were like getting
divorced
oh interesting i missed that that might
have been when they were redefining
their marriage but now they're living
under
one roof together with their family
co-parenting she said we are in
unchartered territories sean and i are
still married i plan on staying married
we are not sleeping in the same bedroom
now but we are in the same house we're
raising our kids together
he's my best friend he knows the girl
i'm dating
wow that's just it's so unique it is
unique she also said um
that getting sober was like
the the cataclysm for this whole thing
because she had never really
been herself and i know that a lot of
people like think that oh bronwyn is
like she has so much going on
but i don't it kind of it like it i'm
watching her story unfolding like it all
makes sense
yeah no it all makes sense and she's so
open she's been open since the beginning
of the season with her sobriety
and now with her new relationship and i
just think it's really commendable and
again like someone living
being themselves living their truth and
it's
it's wonderful it reminded me of what we
were talking about yesterday with elliot
page it's like
you can't help but envy people who just
like have this moment and and
just are so authentically themselves and
you could tell in her interview like she
was definitely
really nervous and she did get choked up
especially when the interviewer from
glad was asking her questions about
shawn and her marriage
um because she's obviously like it's
uncharted territory like she doesn't
have an answer for everything
um and she was being just like really
real and but to even be like so open
about the fact that she doesn't have an
answer for everything
is so commendable as well and it's just
weird that like because she's
you know has this job like she feels the
need to come up with like an explanation
for everything in her life as regards to
her marriage her sexuality
and when she doesn't have like the
perfect answer like she got choked up
like
cause she didn't know what to say she's
like we're figuring it out yeah so
it's i mean if you watch the show you're
not like surprised
but i just um but this also makes her
the first lesbian real housewife
so there's right like technically yes
because barbara kaye
um from real housewives of new york was
a friend of she got demoted before the
season ever started did she ever hold an
apple i don't think she ever have a
tagline no
okay she was meant to be a full-time
housewife but i just don't think they
were impressed with the footage that she
got
okay but then there was also like one of
tamara's friends on the second season of
oc i was doing some research
i didn't follow i didn't remember this
season or this person and i don't know
if she was a full-time housewife but she
was a lesbian too
but like if we were gonna get really
nitpicky i guess you could say like no
but
yes she is got it okay well very
exciting
yeah and i look forward to hearing your
real housewives of orange county recap
oh and um in the preview
for this like upcoming season of real
housewives of orange county
bronwyn's girlfriend i believe it's the
same woman she's seeing um makes like a
cameo
and all the women are like who is this
woman and broadway's like i love her so
i think the timing of the glad interview
was
very um intentional okay because i think
we
we see it more unwrapped i know now i
feel like you're watching real
housewives of orange county no i was
literally thinking the same thing like
now i think that maybe we should because
i will be
i just think it'll be really interesting
i think the timing was yeah this was all
very interesting
i'll catch up this weekend maybe oh and
i caught up on both yesterday
you really couldn't escape last week's
episode lately it was so nothing burger
like okay
i might yeah i really might but that
like just goes against like i know
the i don't know what it goes against
who you are it goes against who i am
like i need to complete things like i
can't change a song in the middle of the
song like you know
okay that is like a thing that you do
that like you get mad unless it's like a
bad song that i've never heard before
and i'm like change the song but like
if i'm in the car and there's like a
playlist playing and like you're just
bored of the song that we love i can't
change it in the middle of the song
yeah i don't agree with it just like i
can't just like skip episodes
oh i can i skipped um last week's
episode of the bachelorette i need to
have
every single piece of information no
because even when i watch i'm like only
half watching so i'm only missing 50
percent
that's me these days that is true okay
now for some beverly hills news we have
two pieces of news the first is that
kyle richards kathy hilton andery
kemsley
all have covid the covet concerns
pausing production on real households of
beverly hills run way deeper than an
infected crew member
tmz has learned that several cast
members also have the virus
sources with direct knowledge told tmz
that kyle kathy and dereet
have also tested positive for coven 19
we're told they're all recovering at
home and none of the women
had serious symptoms this is good the
series started filming its new season
toward the end of october
and tmz sources say that there were
safety protocols in place including
testing and temperature checks
but that couldn't stop a coveted
outbreak from impacting production
yes no i mean this is the world that
we're living in now even though you know
i accidentally left the local news on
yesterday
and i was watching the governor they
said they're going to get 170 000
vaccines on december 15th yeah i mean we
it's for elderly people and
frontline workers which it totally
should be but like they're coming
they're coming that's crazy no it is
crazy i feel like
how did i like just find that out no i
think i read something this morning i
don't want to get it wrong but it was
like a big
number 20 million pertaining to no it
wasn't by middle of february it was
um hold on what i saw was that december
15th it was that a hundred million
people should be able to be vaccinated
by the end of february
fabulous fabulous that is per business
insider so hopefully real housewives of
beverly hills will be able to go on
now obviously this is just par for the
course when you're filming
a show in a pandemic but i cannot
describe
how little i want to see covid on next
season of beverly when covet
i don't want to be watching about
copenhagen it should be voldemort like
you cannot say the name i completely
agree
because i'm dreading watching southern
charm i'm dreading watching oc because
now oc it's like
it's now march 14th like the episode
ended last night it's march 14th like oh
wow
they really slowed that lead up so just
like kill me like
i just ca oh my god i just called her
karen
shannon she was being a karen she was
being a karen
running to costco and paper towels
crying like
she actually does have um she is
considered high risk because she has
bronchial like a lung
um disorder so i get why she was being
so scared about the virus but like she
was being nuts in costco like sending
all of her assistants to costco um
karen badour sorry about that um but
what i'm saying is like now beverly
hills has been infiltrated by colby but
we don't know how they'll
how they'll deal with it and maybe if it
airs in like a literal year from now
and they realize that no one really
wants to watch it they'll just like
like continue on cut it out and pretend
like it never happened like i would be
okay with that
yeah i think that would be okay
i do think it's interesting like which
group got it like do you think there's a
divide in the group and it's kathy
kyle and versus everyone else like how
do only three of them get it when
they're all filming oh
interesting and i feel like jared and
kyle are always sort of butting heads
well maybe they were in the process and
then they had that iconic meal
in rome with the secretary it looks
sickening and so maybe that's the sort
of thing that makes people bound to each
other forever or maybe that's
maybe they were like duking it out kathy
was the mediator
at lunch and that's where they all got
covered yeah or maybe they had another
iconic meal together hopefully one can
hope
one can hope and it was spread in that
way well i hope they're all doing well
and that everyone including the group
member
gets well soon yeah everyone now are you
ready for our next piece of beverly
hills
news today that is like a big piece of
news yes ma'am
erica and tom girardi oh my god are
being sued for allegedly using their
divorce to embezzle money to fund a
lavish
lifestyle so this is a theory that you
actually
i peddled on the show that you peddled
on the show saying that it was
a theory that it was a strategic divorce
not because they don't love each other
but because they knew
they knew that tom was you know on the
horizon had some like bad legal troubles
and in order to protect erica protect
the money they got divorced
so the money was legally erica's and now
that they're not married anymore whoever
is suing tom
can't access that money it's actually
very smart you also did maybe say that
because he was like old and
maybe um no i don't think it's but
that's no no no
that was part of the theory i think
exactly what i just repeated is exactly
what i said you don't need to go back
and watch the episode because i was
totally right
okay one month after erica giardi filed
for divorce from husband tom gerardi the
couple has been sued for allegedly using
their split to embezzle money
according to a complaint filed in an
illinois federal court on wednesday
the rail houses of beverly hills star
and her lawyer husband are being sued by
the law firm
edelson pc on behalf of several families
who lost loved ones in a boeing plane
crash
this is one of the boeing max plane
crashes the flight was the lion air
flight 610.
and so i guess tom's law firm was like
handling the class action yes and the
accusation is that they embezzled
settlement funds
that were meant for families of the
victims of the lion air flight
610 and they're saying that they
embezzled the funds to spend them on
their lavish lifestyle and literally
like the expensive
song and music video are being used as
like evidence because she's saying it's
expensive to be her
okay first of all you can't i remember
an episode of law and otter you can't
use
people's art like their music as
evidence because
art is subjective and years ago she said
that it costs
um forty thousand dollars forty thousand
dollars a month to be her
she did say that she they could use that
but they can't use the music video i
remember the documents sites richard
said they can't use it the documents
cite their
song expensive with a dollar sign okay
that's
not a legit um no but this sounds like
the
case is you know yeah i mean that's
really bad that's true like that's
really bad
taking money from like victims families
yes they said that tom has resorted to
embezzling the proceeds of settlements
that should have been directed to his
clients
including as the basis for this
complaint the widows and orphans who
lost loved ones in the
tragic crash of the lion air flight 610
in order to continue funding
his and erica's lavish beverly hills
lifestyles the document state
these are allegations um at this time
and
they are um will be
dealt with in the courts but i do think
the part of this that is interesting
especially for pop culture is maybe tom
and erica did not fall out of love
by the way and i never thought they did
i just have to say like i believe in
their love a hundred percent
but i first of all this is making me
really sad because i see tom as like
this
really stand up like moral compass
almost like he's always telling erica
like
the right thing to do and we don't see
him a lot but he just seems like this
like good hard-working guy like keeps
his head down and just like makes his
millions
but maybe we're wrong i don't know you
really don't know people on television i
just really hope that this is not
what they're saying it is you know yeah
they said that tom's law firm gerardi
and keith are
also named in the suit which claims that
both tom and the firm are quote on the
verge of financial collapse and locked
in a downward spiral of mounting debts
and dwindling funds
so let's just let's let's plan this out
let's say
like they're guilty and they have no
money left blah blah blah
and obviously erica's still like
fabulous and interesting i actually
think like
even if they are found guilty like
she'll still be on the show
they could also go to jail i don't think
she could
that she's being named ensued i guess
yeah and they're saying that the divorce
is a fraud
so that like they're trying to oh i i i
see they're trying to
legitimize the divorce so that she's
implicated yeah oh no
i don't know what's gonna i we don't
know but these are some major major
claims and of course it begs the
question
is this going to be on the show but i
it's just it's so
legal that i this is like so classic
housewives i can't talk
about it it's a legal matter which
actually this is so legal and you might
not be able to talk about it and that's
what elizabeth
other women talk about it yes how can
you not it's such a big so many of them
have had legal drama like in bev
if this were any other city i would say
of course the women are going to bring
it up but
they have set this precedent of not
talking about each other's legal
business
that's true but this is like i don't
unless they want to bring camille
grammar back on the show i can't think
of another housewive like scandal
that's been even remotely as i mean this
is such a big story
right and it was talked about non-stop
i'm talking about beverly hills sorry oh
like they've all had their little things
uh uh who dorit has had quite a few
things that it's never really been topic
of conversation except
in her confessionals a little bit this
most recent season um kyle
has had stuff with the agency like
everyone has had stuff when and they've
said that on the reunions they're like
our husbands like when you work as big
as they do like lawsuits are just
par for the course i do think that this
is beyond like the standard rich man
and also it makes you think that it's
definitely beyond the standard because
they got
divorced right and it makes you wonder
it just it puts a lot of question marks
around things and yeah and
we'll wait until justice is served
but you know what i don't have a
question very curious you know what i
know
anyone gives me no questions what it's
just like so solid and i can rely on
them all the time oh wow
i what bruce
oh my gosh can i just say go i was
packing like my move happened this
morning and i brushed my teeth and then
i
immediately brought my bruce to the new
apartment because i was like i cannot be
looking for my bruce
all afternoon and all night like i need
my bruce tonight it was literally one of
the most important things that i brought
with me
in my move bruce if you don't know we've
been talking about them for a while the
best electric toothbrush on the market
the most reasonably priced the plenius
jack and i both have this like
millennial baby pink it's so cute
it has a fabulous magnetic stand that
like is not like dirty and doesn't like
get moldy it's just fabulous
bruce is a fabulous product um they
clean your teeth at 31 000 movements a
minute wear manual toothbrushes tap out
at just 300.
many electric toothbrushes are barely a
step up from manual ones and some of
them do a good job but they can cost
over 200 dollars
but bruce delivers premier sonicwave
technology without the markups that big
electric toothbrushes tack on so it's a
fabulous product great for someone in
your life
that you love maybe as a gift and if you
want to get a bruise you can get 15
off when you use the promo code toast at
bruce.com
brucia spelt b-r-u-u-s-h dot com so
that's
brush with two use you can try it 90
days risk free and get a two year
warranty
that's bruce.com promo code toast again
b-r-u-u-s-h
dot com the the bruce kit includes the
electric toothbrush
three brush heads a magnetic charging
station and a sleek
travel case which is probably the best
part because traveling with a toothbrush
is like so much drama and it's like
disgusting when you just like throw it
in
drama yeah right you know that's
literally the best part
yeah because we're always traveling
these days we're such world travelers
it's sickening
sickening okay next story little new
relationship news christelle stauss
appears to be off the market
on wednesday dancing with the stars pro
kio who was paired with anne haiti on
season 29 of the abc competition series
posted some touchy-feely cute photos
with the selling sunset star so there's
like two photos that she put when she
posted one on her story
of her and keo and he's giving her a
kiss on the cheek and then he posted one
it's a different picture but he's also
giving her a kiss on the cheek and he
posted one to his feed with the caption
heart this is like the plot twist of the
century like
everyone was just looking at gleb
krashel gleb krashel and here comes keo
like out of nowhere like
this is just the plot twist nobody saw
coming no
and i'm so happy for her they're really
cute they're such a cute couple
and i guess they waited for the season
to be over
i think i don't know if there's like a
rule because dancing with the stars
they've made many couples but they
always come out as dating after i don't
know why
oh i wonder if there's a rule like even
artem and nikki even though the show
makes you think everyone's dating
right but maybe they don't want even
though it would be like such a ratings
boost for the show if like you thought
two people were falling in love on the
dance floor and then they just like
kissed and like you can like study it
and like figure out but i also feel like
everyone aside from christelle but kia
wasn't even her partner everyone who
falls in love on the show was
is like in a relationship at the time
nikki and john cena
robert herjavic and kim yeah i also
think that most people who fall in love
on the show fall in love with their
partners
right but like they have to get out of
their current environment before they
can announce
i just think it's interesting how she
fell in love with a pro who wasn't her
partner
yeah like because you spend so and
that's why that's why so many couples
come out of dancing with the stars
because it's like those long hard nights
and you just like work so hard together
and it's like
perfect place to fall in love heightened
emotions um i don't even know if you see
the other pros like that you're not
paired up with
yeah especially during the coveted times
right but then they also are sort of in
a bubble and so it's kind of like camp
right and like maybe you're just going
over to another bunk
maybe maybe this is cute this is cute i
look forward to keeping tabs on this
blossoming relationship and i would love
to get like some sort of timeline of
like
when selling sunset is being filmed is
was she filming while she was on dancing
with the stars because they were
confirmed for a fourth season but then
also cove it happened so
i just want to know like what part of
christelle's a year are we gonna see
yeah i just feel like how i always feel
which is they're filming now
yeah no i i feel but you know what i
always think about how it's like
okay real housewives of beverly hills is
on for what like five or six months out
of the year
so it's like what do is that wrong that
seems like a long time but i don't think
you're wrong
no it's like it's 20 usually like 20
episodes 20 episodes
is five months yeah continue okay so i
always think about it's like oh how like
housewives and just like reality stars
work like a half of the year
but then it's like the other half of the
year they're filming it's airing
they're doing press doing the reunion
and then they start filming again like
it's really a year-round job yeah i just
just thought of that um speaking of
reality stars who we absolutely love
the kardashians are pulling pranks on
facetime to some of their famous pals
if you haven't seen this video yet pause
this episode go to chloe's instagram or
kylie's tick tock
and watch the video on her feed
basically all the kardashians are
together right now yeah are they in palm
springs
no they're in a mountain vibe uh they
were ice skating i think they're skiing
um well so i just maybe they're in
wyoming oh maybe yeah
in the ski vibe yeah so we have kendall
kylie chris
kim courtney chloe they're all together
they're sitting
at like a it's a tick tock trend so
these girls and the girls must be
freaking out who started it they're
college girls
and they started facetiming all the
dudes and like their like brother
fraternity and like
they just sat in front of the camera six
girls like staring blank at the phone
and wanted to see how the guys reacted
and now it's become a trend on tic tac
but the girls who started like must be
freaking out the kardashians did it i
didn't even know it was a trend i mean
after i saw it i kind of figured that it
might be
but it's so amazing so imagine you pick
up a facetime call and it's
all of the kardashian women like staring
right at you i mean you also would be
friends with them so like so it would be
like that big of a deal
that would be exciting whose phone do
you think they were using kylie's i
think
yeah i think kylie's also just based on
how she had people's names in her phone
like she had
travis scott as just a couch
that would make me feel like it was
someone else because oh no i feel like
everyone else would just have a
sauce i i agree i mean
the video was so interesting for a
multitude of reasons but one because i
loved seeing how kylie or whoever's
phone it was like had people's numbers
saved like
first second i love seeing like who's
the number they have like
really i thought the most shocking
person was dave chappelle well then
maybe it's like maybe it's kim's phone
or kanye like yeah but then also sauce
kanye does not have sausages now no i
mean his phone i
really still feel oh addison ray yeah
that by the way that was crazy and i was
surprised addison didn't know the trend
because it's a tick-tock trend i thought
she was going to be like oh she
literally was so awkward like i actually
felt bad for her that is
no it was so funny then justin bieber
haley bieber um
dave grutman lucas abbott
taco taco yes no it was
just so pretty if you don't know the
trend like you think you're in trouble
like you think you're about to have a
sitting down yeah
tristan saw his life flash before his
eyes
and so they recorded everyone's
reactions and it's just like
so deeply interesting so and by the way
they were just like i watched it
so many times because there were just so
many things i couldn't get over like i
needed
more like they kept like they just it
was too short like i needed more
i just thought people were being so
funny i thought i mean i'm just so
obsessed like head over heels and love
dave chappelle like
i just thought his reaction was so funny
of course he's smoking a cigarette like
inside his house like he's just the man
like i loved this so much and this is
yet not that anyone asked but if anyone
needed more proof as to like how the
kardashians are just like
the reigning queens of social media of
celebrity of hollywood like this is the
proof like
look at them yeah look at them it's
really like they sat and did nothing and
literally
i love that they're all together right
now i just i hope they're filming
something for us
i know i feel like they're not i feel
like they might be they have one more
season of kardashians i know i just feel
like
the show is like really taking a
backseat to like i actually i'm gonna
put i'm gonna put it all out there i
think they're filming okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna say it okay because
they like have a heart they don't get
together
well that's the thing it's i actually
feel like covet has been really good for
the kardashians because remember how
like in years past they couldn't get
together
for one afternoon to do the christmas
family photo shoot like literally
that none of them between their work and
their family couldn't spare one
afternoon for a photo shoot
and now it's like everything has slowed
down they're probably spending so much
time together it's probably so nice
with all the kids too yes also okay upon
further examination of these photos in
the justin bieber
video versus the travis scott video it
looks like two different phones
so they might have been using because
this one looks like it doesn't have a
phone case on
but this one does very interesting so
like justin and haley was definitely
from kylie's phone dave chappelle was
definitely from
kim's phone travis was oh they probably
thought like who would
travis and dave chappelle look like
they're on the same phone tristan maybe
it's like chloe's phone
yeah i don't know i maybe i'm not seeing
it right but look at those two pictures
one looks like a phone case on the phone
and one looks like oh my god these are
two totally different phones
we crack the case i just i loved it so
much
and you know i feel like i don't really
know travis scott's personality and i
would just assume him to be
really quiet i don't know i don't know
why i've always just felt like he was
like an introvert
i don't know him personally and when he
picked up the phone he was like being so
loud and funny i was like oh my god
that's what you're like yeah you know
you just don't really know people
no it's a great way to get to know
people do it again
i just need more we should do it no i
know but like did all of our friends
watch the show
no and the thing is it's like nobody
ever picks up my phone calls so i was
thinking like how do they get everyone
to pick up
well yeah maybe it was chris's phone
you pick up you pick up on chris jenner
calls but it's not like people are
ignoring me it's like i'm on my phone
twenty four seven three i'm sure there
are people who didn't pick up this call
and now they're ruining the day
oh my god they're literally like stewing
in their homes like
can't believe that they missed out on
the opportunity of a lifetime 100
okay ready for our fifth and final story
a little biz news
wow it's been so long since we had a
little biz news
and you know what it's actually some big
business like bb
hbw it's bbn we did a whole
patreon episode about biz news last week
um
because they were like great topic
topics of conversation for when you're
with your family at thanksgiving but
people are saying with their families
from thanksgiving
through the new year so head over to
patreon.com to get all the business that
you need to know to like really converse
with your family now yeah if you don't
know what astrazeneca is
check out the patreon episode because i
didn't know what it was either okay but
here's some
mergers and acquisition news is it the
mergers and acquisition news
that has to do with my book honestly no
oh really that's shocking i thought
wow i'm shocked but while i'm here my
book is now available
no it's not sorry my book comes out it's
available for pre-order it comes out
january
26 2021 um it's called growth in the job
the crazy beautiful life of an instagram
thirst monster it is autobiographical it
is really honestly very very funny
i just recorded the audiobook so if you
want to pre-order it which i would
really appreciate the pre-order because
i need good pre-order numbers
in order to get into like bookstores and
airports which is my goal um
so the audiobook is available for
pre-order which is like audible google
play
the obviously like hardcover book is
available at amazon barnes noble and
then the
what do you call it like electric ebook
ebook electric book
is available at um all the places for
kindle and all the places so if you just
go to girlsnojob.com
book you'll get all the links um check
it out
check it out okay here's the bbn okay oh
yeah i forgot
salesforce you know salesforce okay i
know i'm so glad you brought this up
salesforce is a huge company like it's
actually a crm powerhouse
got it according to techcrunch what do
they sell like sales
forces okay so they finished it the
company that nick viall worked at before
he
went on that sorry yes that is very very
interesting factoid no but i just i know
like they have a huge building in bryant
park i know it's like one of the biggest
companies in the world but like it's
like what do the people who work there
dude
it's like back end like b2b stuff you
know
it's not for the consumer like you
that's why i don't know what it is it's
a business
business you know what i mean a business
to business that's b2b
okay just you learn something new yep um
but salesforce
is buying slack you know slash so this
is like some real
corporate ass news in a 27.7 billion
dollar
mega deal okay for like aim this is like
dramatic
no i know but it's a big deal see this
is where the world loses me like
it's a big deal literally like it's
literally imessage
i mean it's a little more interesting
than that seven billion dollars have you
ever used slack
not once i have used slack when working
at a company it's definitely very
nice for streamlining corporate
communications but 27.7 billion dollars
worth of corporate communications i
didn't see that one coming
see tech is just so confusing to me the
way they like value
like random like companies you know yeah
and i watch shark tank and i know that
it's supposed to be seven times your
gross profit
and i just don't feel like slack is
making seven
divided by 27 billion you know yeah i
mean
i don't know how they do make i mean
obviously they make money but i don't
they don't have ads
no but like companies they pay companies
have to pay to use yeah that makes sense
anyway salesforce co-founder and ceo
mark benioff i wonder if he's related to
the creator of game of thrones
didn't mince words on his latest
purchase he said this is a match made in
heaven
together salesforce and slack will shape
the future of enterprise software
and transform the way everyone works in
the all digital work from anywhere
world that's actually very true work
from anywhere
yeah wfh slack off with slack
that's actually very true i feel like
coupled together yeah it's like this is
like i think
has been very good to slack got it as if
the billion dollar company needed any
more money needed more billions
okay this actually makes sense like i'm
i'm understanding the deal more
yeah and i just feel like that's just
something that you can keep in your back
pocket if you're ever talking to someone
sometimes when you're on like a date
with someone who might work in the
b2b space and you're like oh what do you
think about the salesforce slack merger
or they're talking how do you think that
will affect your day-to-day
communications or the date is like oh
you know my co-workers slacked me this
morning she was really giving me [ __ ]
it's like oh it's being a slack
27 million bam hit them with that dude
and hit them with that 27.7 because i
think that shows you really pay
attention to the numbers
yeah yeah yeah so many mergers and
acquisitions these days we've talked
about a few
on our uh patreon podcast mccormick
buying cholula for 800 million
yes um random house buying simon
schuster for an undisclosed amount
yes why do they choose to disclose and
not disclose like sometimes i think all
mergers and acquisitions
should be disclosed just because it's so
interesting and fascinating and we'd
love to report on it
yeah like 800 million dollars for
cholula but 27 billion for slack like
how did we get here that doesn't add up
no a hundred percent
that's so crazy when you think about it
that way okay now into our tv recap
segment real housewives of salt lake
city and i'll touch on oc a little bit
because i did watch
and the tv recap segment is brought to
you by honey
you're probably wondering oh sorry
you're probably wondering
is this the same honey that
automatically searches for promo codes
online
yes yes it is with honey you can also
make a list of all the holiday gifts you
want from certain stores and honey will
email you when the price drops
on anything on your list what a fabulous
um
setting yeah i didn't know that um just
add honey to your computer
create a free account and throw some
holiday gifts on your drop list for a
chance to win
honey will randomly select winners and
give them the money to help them buy
something on their list this year
wow so honey's giving back and also
honey it's basic feature
is just you install it on your browser
as an extension and anytime you're
shopping at popular stores
i use it at bloomingdale sephora like
pretty much any popular store target
and they will scour the internet without
even you asking them they'll just do it
on their own
and pop up and be like hey use this
let's use this promo code and save 15
they do it at revolve they find the most
random promo codes and revolve is
expensive so like
it really makes a difference far-fetched
so honey is totally free to download
and they save you money so i don't
really understand why someone
wouldn't download it um
get honey for free at joinhoney.com
toast
so the website is joinhoney.com
toast you can get honey completely free
and if you want to be a part of their
holiday giveaway no purchase is
necessary you just need a paypal account
to redeem the prize
it's only valid for us giveaway for u.s
and the giveaway ends
december 21st 2020. so um
there's just some some things i've been
waiting on especially things for kaler
that are like kind of expensive for the
holiday season
so i have added them to my drop list um
and it's a fabulous feature that they'll
alert you anytime something that you
want goes down in price and then you can
enter in the giveaway so check it out
joinhoney.com toast check it out
especially as you're shopping for the
holidays make sure to get the best deals
possible
yeah so people can get the get best
gifts possible and there are so many
deals going around it's like hard to
keep
up with like all the deals yeah exactly
okay so let's do salt lake city first
yes just in order of importance
so sensational like really enjoyed and
they didn't waste any time like
there was three events you know
heather's baby shower for her employees
whitney's 20s whatever party and then
mary's luncheon like they really did not
stop yes and i just want to say like i
really i'm judging the women based on
the events that they're throwing
and i loved whitney's event like i know
it wasn't as like fancy as jen shaw's
party for meredith
but it was seemed really fun and like a
good ass time
agreed 100 love whitney and i especially
love whitney and heather are like my
tied for first
heather is my queen like i just [ __ ]
love her she said so many she's like
so many funny when she was on the phone
with sharif and was like
make a right you'll see me i'm the
flapper with cankles so funny
when she didn't want to go to the fight
because her uh lollipop
her lollipop chicken drumsticks were
coming and then they did come and then
she had to follow jen outside and she
said watch the lollipop chicken don't
clear the table that's so important
they're always clearing tables when
you're not done that was so funny and
that's how i knew like she was my person
like yes
she was being so funny last night
without getting involved in any drama
and that's such a unique to come out
like the favorite from an episode
and not have been a part of any of the
drama like that is a very unique
actually the only one who didn't get up
to console either woman chicken
drumsticks no and also because like
she just i don't think that she needed
to i think everyone who was like going
to console gem because they were worried
that gem would be mad at her
if they didn't like i think one person
doing that is fine like the whole group
is unnecessary i think she was also like
beyond
being reasoned with at that point yes
whitney was very um
astute in observing she's like i'm just
going over to say
like take care of jen just so she
doesn't get mad at me if i didn't yeah
for not
taking care of her so i really like
gensha but this was not a good episode
first she was being so
so unreasonable two episodes now and
wrote because i watched them together
last weekend this week so i don't know
which one was which but yeah this whole
idea that she won't be friends with
meredith because meredith
talks to and hangs out with mary from
time to time
after what mary did to her which at the
end of the day was just commenting that
she smelled like hospital because she
had been in the hospital by the way mary
was wrong for her but they buried it
so why are we acting like this was not
very also even if they hadn't squashed
it
or no even if they squashed it but you
know what mary did was like one of those
things you always keep in the back of
your mind
like jen keeps saying she came for my
family she came for my family but just
because she smelled like hospital like
that's not it like that she didn't come
for the family
that's not a big enough gripe to make
all your friends stop talking to this
person yep and i have so much
respect for meredith because i i don't
like this idea especially when someone
really didn't do anything very wrong
they just said something that you didn't
like i don't like this idea of like
you're my friend that means you can't
talk to people who i don't like
right or this idea that like no one can
be neutral that's like what we're
experiencing in potomac right now with
karen hugh you're like
people should be allowed to be
switzerland yeah and i feel very
strongly about that yeah but i also feel
like
that like that this just highlight
comparing it to potomac
highlights how much of a nothing burger
is like candace and monique are in court
like right
she just said you smell like hospital
yeah no it's so i feel like jen is
really just trying to like make her mark
as a housewife
and she doesn't care if she's like wrong
or right she just wants to like have a
moment of throwing a wine glass or
screaming in a parking lot but i also
think that some of the contacts that she
gave us in last night's episode between
um feeling lonely because her husband's
always on the road and it's the one-year
anniversary of her dad's death i can
understand why she
pre-gamed this party and then sort of
got really emotional and
i think it's it can be amended 100
and when she went to the luncheon and
she apologized to meredith i feel like
they're on a good page
she needs to apologize to mary because i
don't know if she knows though that mary
heard her say
call her a grandfather [ __ ] no but i
think that what she would say to that is
like yeah you do [ __ ] your grandfather
which
you know but she needs to apologize mary
not for that comment but just for the
way that she's been treating her and
trying to get other people to stop being
her friend
they need to start from zero because if
jen had any sort of
case with the hospital smell thing she
lost it's over oh my god
and and it's okay after she like
completely had a meltdown at the party
but we can start new and i feel like
that's what mary's luncheon was and jen
again and it blows up next week jen was
sharing at the table her experience
growing up and why she is the way she is
and i thought it was a perfect segue
to explain why she got to that place
and then also just apologize and move on
from it but she's not doing that
let me tell you how i've so turned from
from really disliking mary
i still don't fully understand her but i
thought seeing her at church was just
like a great moment because
first of all the people in her
congregation like the way they look at
her
so emotional i just felt like this has
to be a special person and so like i i
think she's kind of quirky
but i think that makes her who she is
and why she's such a great congregation
leader
and also a great person on television
the way that she just like
prayed so hard over whitney's dad and
like he was crying like i was like
living for that when she was like in let
us say and i thought she was going to
say amen
and i literally i could like i was
literally like
so in it no i totally agree like i just
thought wow this is a great person like
i just
i was turned starting to turn towards
her side
and i thought just the way she handled
herself this entire episode where with
dread like jen
acting like an animal and like treating
mary like [ __ ] and mary just like
literally being a queen like so poised
it's very hard to do when someone's
coming after you especially calling you
a grandfather [ __ ]
i just thought there's more to mary than
that meets the eye
that's what i've been trying to tell you
you know you're totally and so i i
really like her i'm very much interested
by her
i thought her luncheon was so
interesting because it wasn't just like
the most fabulous luncheon because
it was fabulous but it was also so
interesting and like the louis vuitton
and the engraving and the fish
the embossed uh the fish and the caviar
the caviar the fish on the table yes the
red carpet the
buckingham palace guards when they were
like i don't think a thousand dollar
truffle
i don't think that mary knows what the
met gala is she just like saw it and
wants that vibe like i was like oh yeah
i guess not
like it was so it's just very elegant it
was very elegant but also like quirky
and interesting
which is so merry which is so merry um
the other thing i wanted to say was
quickly on
meredith and lisa so i agree like i so
love meredith and like the way jen shaw
acted in their house in front of their
kids was
absurd oh okay this is so interesting
because i agreed but then
i was on twitter and first of all
apparently in like the first episode
jen shaw is wearing an outfit from
brooks's clothing line like supporting
him on the show it literally is a track
suit that says max burks down the side
and so it's like he's going to pretend
like he's never met her yet she's
literally like helping him
and promoting his fashion line and
people are really starting to turn on
brooks
is what i've seen you know they were
like i thought this guy was going to be
like the comedic like
instead he's just like a brat oh no
i gotta get on twitter and also people
are saying like they're just reading
through him coming home from college to
be with his mom they're
he came home from college to be on real
housewives 100
when he said that he came over from
college when his parents got
separated i'm like all right people get
divorced all the time like it's really
not nothing to leave school
and also like i've never seen a woman
more fine than meredith so fine but what
i wanted to say was i thought i really
i haven't been like what goes on i
haven't been liking lisa
like i just feel like she's really fake
and like she's just so like
she's she's the type of girl if i knew
her personally like i would run from
like
she just gives me such bad vibes but i
actually thought when meredith told her
about her divorce and like she got
really choked up like i actually thought
that was really sincere it was like the
first time i saw
lisa be a real person and not like i
want to be real housewife bethany friend
plus the fact that she's the only
housewife who like knows on a personal
level rach parcell
yeah speaks volumes no no and it's like
we we gotta get to know her like
no i like those two things i agree like
i'm going to give her another chance
but there's something about her that
just rubs me as like been waiting to be
a housewife her entire life
for this moment is now and like
everything that comes out of her mouth
is just like a canned response
that she thinks will be made into a gif
that will go viral on twitter
yes but also yesterday you and i after
the show spent about two hours like on a
deep dive rach parcell and her family
like rabbit hole just because we're like
so obsessed with them and like
they're decor like we're just obsessed
like and we wanted to know more and
i just got so lost in that and then i
went home and immediately watched the
most recent episode of salt lake city
and i'm like this show would be
so good if rach marcel was on it i know
and i know she's too good for her
because she's like a really good mormon
and
i like i know that it will never happen
and the mormon church like would allow
her to be on it
i know and i'm just like that's that
upsets me because we need a rach parcell
moment like
she's just so fabulous but she's so
fantastic salt lake city has brought me
nothing out like it's brought me so much
but if at the end of the day all it
brings me is that it introduced me to
rach parcell
it's it would be enough dying you guys
we are so
like deeply obsessed you should have
seen my browser history is like so
embarrassing it's like rachmarcell.com
like
rachel parcell home and her amazon
fashion picks she also has like a
a home line at nordstrom and if anyone's
listening like can we get more
on the home front like i'm not really i
don't need ornaments like i need like a
rage parcel's whole house in a box
i need a rachel dining table yeah like
if anyone's listening please we digress
we digress
overall it's a good episode it's a great
series the women are great and like i
love it
yes overall i totally agree and i'm
liking everyone
more and more and i i i do
i'm liking lisa more because i feel like
maybe at the end of this
i don't know i'm gonna give her a chance
but something was just like rubbing me
the wrong way but i'm really enjoying
meredith
and i didn't know the ladies and also
people someone said like meredith is a
combination of lisa vanderpump and kyle
richards and like i completely see that
looks or behavior looks you have to look
at it you have to see them
i kind of actually do i do see the lisa
vanderpump for sure and i love her style
yes me too it's like very elegant
there's so much great style i love jen's
shot style
obviously me too and i love meredith
style i enjoy lisa's style i enjoy mary
style and i think heather and whitney
are just like
so [ __ ] cute and i think they're very
utah when they were in the car in the
way of the luncheon and the conversation
that they were having was just like
two people talking yeah not two people
filming the show it was just like two
cousins like
chad and i also thought that jen like
just because meredith spoke to someone
that jen
doesn't like today jen sharing that
meredith
is separated i'm so glad you brought
that up she is now in the wrong
jackie i'm so glad you brought that up i
audibly gasped for what she said that
i'm like are you
meredith is such and she also say nobody
knows don't tell so then heather goes
and tells whitney
and then whitney's like everyone's
wondering why didn't meredith tell me
and it's like because the news isn't out
yet no i thought that was so
[ __ ] up and honestly like really
really mean like i
i it turned me yeah
okay now really quickly about real
housewives of orange county i just
nothing happened like i can't i can't
stress that enough like really nothing
happened
except all the women are now just like
coming for elizabeth being like why do
not stop talk about
your divorce your ex-husband like let
the money go gene is like going through
this it'll just like it'll keep you like
just let it go i've been there
let what go stop talking about it or
like get out of court both
get out of court yeah it's like
elizabeth said she is enough right now
to like to live for the rest of her life
but it's just it's not
what she deserves okay and they're in
palm springs and this house that she has
in palm springs that they built together
it's 10 000 square feet on the golf
course like it's just eating her up
being in palm springs and she's talking
about it a lot because her house is
literally down the road
and she can't get into it and she's just
mad like she has all this
pent up anger she gave up having kids
for this man then he like cheated on her
and had a baby with someone else and
she's just mad
and she wants her [ __ ] money and
she's like i grew up so poor and
i think the way that she described this
i actually like respected her on her
it was so honest she was like i grew up
so poor and i worked so hard just so
nobody would know that i was like the
poor mexican girl and she's like
and and look how far that got me like
that mentality and she's like i'm just
not ready to give that up
but at the same time that money is so
toxic and like
and i hate it too so i don't know she's
just like very self-aware
and then women are just like now it
sounds like honest the women are just
like clowning her for like
talking about it so much and like she
talks about it with jimmy and the women
are like jimmy's gonna leave you like if
you don't stop talking about it like
you're annoying us
and elizabeth took it all so well she's
like oh my god i'm so sorry i didn't
mean to annoy you guys like i'm just
like going
she didn't get mad she didn't cry she
took all this like criticism that i
thought was so unwarranted
giving how long we've had to listen to
some of these women shannon
talking about we saw shannon at the
courthouse talk about their
[ __ ] divorce i'm like you're
really coming for this girl who's
gina so then then what's so funny is
gina was like
you really need to stop talking about it
with jimmy
he doesn't want to hear about this
tattoo
literally gina playing tennis with her
[ __ ] new boyfriend
talking about matt how like one of the
women in the softball league is like
talking [ __ ] about matt trying to make
him seem like a bad dad blah blah
like you're like you are the uh
hunchback who cannot see his own hunch
like it was so
[ __ ] like obviously hypocritical and
i just
i can't stand gina i try i try so hard i
can't stand her and that's the end of
what i have to say okay you made it
sound good i think i'm gonna watch
yeah maybe i'm like looking too much
into it but it's just no i trust your
intuition
gina and you know so we're here for
elizabeth
100 and and i i have something to admit
like and i'm really sad to say this but
like my queen emily
what happened i just i'm getting the
vibe that she's getting like a little
high on her horse like with the other
like tamara gone and vicki on and like
she's now fun emily and everyone like
loves her i'm just
i don't want to put it out there but
like i'm getting the vibe like she needs
to
take a seat do you know what i mean i do
know what you mean
you'll see i could see that happening
yeah but they gave a preview and
uh shane had coveted really bad
shannon gets covered um a bunch of them
do oh okay interesting i'm gonna watch
and then hopefully next week we can
recap it so i can yeah i think we should
add it back to the plate like with the
brush
i think it could still be optional
because i think it was like very it's
nice knowing you don't have to watch
something but that you
want to but the thing is is that real
housewives of salt lake city is on at 10
o'clock so like you might as well just
watch oc at nine well for me last night
it i was watching the episode for from
last week because i didn't watch it last
week because we were off
yeah um okay well that's our show
jackie's gotta go move so thank you guys
so much for listening to the morning
toast we'll see you tomorrow
hope you have a great day and we'll see
you tomorrow thanks for listening to the
sorry i'm like i'm going in circles i
know yeah so you don't want me to move
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast life
stories every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching us on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so it's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio ir
radio cast box
all the places wherever you listen to
podcast find us morning toast leave a
five star view about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are
we hope you have an amazing day we'll
see you tomorrow for friday